tonight it's for Kobe the grammys made
sure to honor Kobe Bryant following the
helicopter crash that left him daughter
Gigi and seven others dead on Sunday
we're all feeling crazy sadness right
now because earlier today Los Angeles
America and the whole wide world lost a
hero and we're literally standing here
heartbroken in the house that Kobe
Bryant built host Alicia Keys kicked
things off with a tribute to him
alongside voice to men it's so hard
to say goodbye
coby's jerseys were also lit up and on
full display Alicia wanted the world to
know how much Kobe loved music
[Music]
so we gotta make this a celebration in
his
you
want us to keep the vibrations from
their celebs let us know he was with
them in Spirit Lake Liz Oh in her first
acceptance speech this whole week you
know I'd be lost in my problems stressed
out and then in an instant all of that
can go away and your priorities really
shift I realized that there's people
hurting right now
when lil NAS acts and Billy Ray Cyrus
took the stage they saved a spot for
Kobe's Lakers day
Koby going out with me on stage tonight
you know being here again we're in the
center of Los Angeles and nas said this
dj khaled also had a message for the
goat and his daughter and John Legend
said this we've seen so much tragedy
today and last year and so much has gone
on but let's love each other let's love
our families let's hold each other tight
god bless ahead of the show celebs
opened up to et about losing Kobe it
really makes you think about how a lot
of things I don't know it's really hard
to talk about it's so sudden and so
random and like his beautiful girl and
like I I have no words my condolences I
don't know what to say
my immediate feeling is that it pulls me
close to my family my friendships
relationships with people you know
people it's about people and especially
our night like tonight when it's all
fraught with lots of other sort of ego
fears and concerns and insecurities the
relationships and friendships is
everything I stopped and I just had to
pick up the phone and call my mama and
say I love you you know I just want you
to know that I mean does it make you
feel like you want to hug your people a
little tighter Kobe goes beyond just
basketball and he's like an icon a
legend overall and um no I hate I hate
did that happen yeah when I'm not on
camera I'm crying and my whole family is
we just I just can't stop crying and
even to think of it and Kobe was such a
great man living oz said it best not
only was he a legend in sports but he
was a legend as a man as a father and
just a great role model and it's a it's
a very sad tragic day and and
bittersweet for all of us here at the
Grammys I mean it just doesn't feel real
he was a legend
it's crazy too that it happens today the
he's here at Staples Center we spent you
know more than a decade lighting this
place up so but someone that Kobe he's
bigger than an icon you know so it's
less is that he's gone is he's he's
forever he's forever
you